high in the himalayas these men are
building a tunnel in freezing
temperatures and in some of the world's
toughest terrain it's very very
challenging now the temperature is going
around 2 degree and we are expecting the
temperature will go minus 25 degree also
within a span of 15 to 20 days and we
plan to continue our work
the zojila tunnel in indian-administered
kashmir will be one of the longest in
asia and run between the ladakh region
and the kashmir valley
it's an area that is both politically
sensitive and strategically important
the valley is in kashmir where control
is divided between india and pakistan
though both claim serenity over the
entire area
china also claimed some areas and ladakh
is along the de facto china-india border
during the winter heavy snow blocks the
only road leading to ladakh the tunnel
will connect the two districts and ease
movement for indian soldiers deployed
there it will only ease our troops right
now in peace time it'll ease their uh
you know russian food equipment because
they they're you know
inducting a lot of heavy equipment there
so all of this can go by a road now and
it can go through the winter this
passage will not be closed
this huge infrastructure project comes
after new delhi promised more and faster
development construction is expected to
be completed in 2023 and it will reduce
travel time between the two regions from
three hours to just 15 minutes
many people are pleased
the road to sonamark remains closed for
four months beginning november and we
have to stay home with no work these
tunnels will benefit business
other tunnels and bridges are also in
the works all part of india's push for
faster growth near its border with china
pavli mithal al jazeera new delhi